hey everyone
this is manish from simply learn and
welcome to this video on
email marketing full course in this
whole course we will learn all about one
of the most trendy technologies today
that is email marketing we'll begin this
full course video with what email
marketing is
and how to set up email marketing the
benefits of it
and a b testing after this we'll look
into the different types of email
campaigns
and how to engage new users with your
emails along with
a hands-on demo using the mailchimp tool
we will then conclude this video by
discussing the essential interview
questions and answers to help
every individual crack an interview by
the end of this video
i can assure you that all your email
marketing career related queries
would have been answered for this
training with me
i have a experienced email marketing
specialist rob
and rahul together we will take you
through the various topics of email
marketing
so let's start with an exciting video on
email marketing
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
welcome everyone this is rob sanders
with simply learn
and welcome today we're going to talk
about email marketing tutorial
so buckle up and let's get started
with email marketing tutorial and so
let's start out asking the question
why email marketing so linda
is the owner of an e-commerce company
and
basically she isn't able to take her
leads the leads she's collecting
per day per month and convert them into
customers
okay so customers sign up but they don't
buy her product so
she's left scratching her head wondering
what to do
so how she gonna solve the problem of
converting
the lead she gets into paying customers
well look no further than email market
so you can boost
your sales funnel with the help of email
marketing
so email marketing leads to email
campaigns that lead to website visits
that can lead to product purchasing
email markings also in a
it's a very good way to generate a high
return
on investment so linda thinks this is
too good to be true
your telling me is a very efficient way
to generate
a return on my investment how expensive
is email marketing well email marketing
is neither expensive or time consuming
that's the beauty of email marketing
and so linda is now very
interested we've piqued her interest she
wants
us to explain email marketing to her in
detail and that's exactly what we're
going to do
buckle up and let's get started and talk
about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda
it's an efficient way to convert leads
into sales
why because we can send personalized
emails to
a specific audience a targeted audience
if somebody's interested in our products
we can reach out to them via email it
can also be used to re-market
pre-qualified leads
so anybody who's pre-qualified we can go
ahead
and communicate with them as well so
email marketing is
very effective at different stages in
the funnel
okay so when i say funnel customer life
cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so
let's talk about each one of these parts
of the
funnel or customer life cycle if you
will so let's start with awareness at
the very top
so email marketing allows customers to
recognize
their problems after which you can
educate them on how your brand can solve
them
okay just like any other marketing
channel
somebody's looking for something in need
of something and we can come to the
rescue in this case we're going to come
to the rescue
with email and we can go ahead and
educate them
on what their need is and how we can
collaborate with them
help them educate them solve their
problems with
our product okay so that's what email's
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email
and we're going to bring awareness to
the problem by solving the problem
that's what email is good for
okay good for generating awareness for
our brand
for example we can share a newsletter
with our customers
so we're running a cosmetics company
we can basically educate them on the
five important skin care products that
everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more
so if somebody's having some skin care
issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so
customers focused on searching for
relevant products
and compares the products with similar
ones okay
so they're definitely looking they're a
little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so
we can really hit them with the right
email we can send a relevant email to
promote
our product okay discover that perfect
moisturizer for your skin that perfect
skin moisturizer
smooths hydrates and contains spf 20. so
we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel
and really is ready to purchase that
product so we can hit that person up
with the perfect messaging to talk about
purchase the next step
in the life cycle well purchase well
with purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer
purchase our product by offering them
something
okay by giving an offer for example we
can give a discount
discounts always tend to work so that
moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying
well they can move from consideration to
purchasing because
we're gonna offer them a discount they
can't refuse okay so
you know it could beat for a specific
date okay
it could be you know something that's
going to get them excited to buy the
product 20
off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other
products they were considering buying so
getting somebody that
extra incentive to purchase the product
goes a long way
via email okay we want to take that next
step in the life cycle and nurture
our relationship with customers to
ensure they're
loyal okay they've already purchased how
do we get them
purchased again that's retention we want
to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product or similar
products
or completely different products in our
inventory so what do we do we're going
to send an email
we're going to send an email to active
customers okay we're going to
give them an offer just for them
exclusively
just for them in this example we're
gonna give them a combo pack a facial
kit at just
39 and get a sunscreen worth ten dollars
for free
so you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations
on offers key is the offer is
exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers
because if you just get somebody to
purchase once it's not going to work
those people have already
taken the that step in the relationship
where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and
treat that customer special by giving
them an exclusive offer
and then what we want to do is advocacy
last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer
into brand advocates okay we want that
customer
to talk about our brand for us we want
them to promote it and talk about it
with your friends
so for example we want to send an email
to those customers to promote
our products okay so for example we
could say hey
the sales of our products for this
particular day or for this month
is going to go to our favorite
non-profit could be educating poor
children
or cleaning up plastic in the ocean or
saving animals we want to be able to get
them to speak on our behalf and say look
guys this is a really good company
you know they're offering me products
exclusively
they've offered me discounts in the past
they have good products they have a lot
of different products
and on top of all that they help they
help the environment they help
the needy okay they care and so
we can go ahead and provide a call to
action
for these customers that are loyal to
our brand
and have them share the email with their
friends to spread the word
on you know what we're trying to
accomplish for our non-profit or
if anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount
for every friend that they get to buy a
product okay it doesn't have to
necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be that extra incentive
of giving them a discount if they do
share with friends and their friends buy
okay so this is the customer life cycle
and examples of different emails that
you can use at every step
along the way in the life cycle so let's
talk about
email marketing setup so email marketing
setup we have a series of steps that we
need to go through
in order to get our email set up
to go ahead and send out to our target
audience and that first step is we want
to identify that target audience and
create segments so if you've taken some
of my and listened to some of my
webinars in the past about google
analytics
about google ads we talk about
segmenting
so it's about targeting a specific
audience that's what segmenting is
taking a piece of the whole so we don't
want to email all users
on our list all customers maybe we want
to target a specific
segment okay so we want to be able to
identify that segment who is that
segment is it somebody who
or a group of people or you know a
partial list
of our customers who purchase a specific
product
i would say so versus say our entire
list of customers because our entire
list of customers can purchase
a number of different products and so by
targeting a specific
segment of our audience or our customer
base
we can hone in on the message so if they
all have something in common like they
all
bought that moisturizer then we can go
ahead
and be specific with our messaging then
we want to create campaigns and set an
appropriate call to action
okay so what is it that we want to say
to these these people
this segment of users then once you
create that campaign
and and set up the messaging and call to
action we want to test the email
before we actually click send this is a
very important step
test that email before we
send and then when we send the campaigns
immediately
or we can schedule a time so my
advice here is always schedule a time
you want to be able to figure out
the best time to send that email
and then once the email is sent whenever
that is you want to be able to analyze
performance
and there are some key metrics that you
want to hone
in on when we talk about email marketing
and some of those are
open rates click-through rates okay
response rate okay so
we want to be able to hone in on certain
key
metrics when it comes to emails so
here's what we need to do
create our list add contacts to our list
create our campaign
okay we want to select the list choose a
format
modify the template and then send the
email campaign so
these are some basic checklists that you
want to do so let me give you an example
and go to mailchimp so if i'm in
mailchimp
basically i'm going to create a campaign
okay
so it's an email that i'm going to work
with
and you can see with mailchimp i have
some some examples here regular
automated
plain text or a b test i want to do a
regular email
and i'm just going to call it test and
i'm going to click begin
okay so we want to add our recipients
who are we going to add
so we're going to choose our audience
okay
so we're just going to choose a sample
test for now okay
we can personalize the two fields if we
want
okay so what do we want to do we want to
call people by their first name their
last name the first
and last name where we can customize it
just go with first name to keep it a
little bit personal
okay then we have the subject line here
so it's all about
messaging right so whoever we're
targeting
we want to be able to add a message so
we're just gonna say and and subject
line is very key here so you want to
have a subject line that's really going
to resonate
with your audience so whoever that
segment audience is
we want to make sure that the subject
line is going to resonate with them
with them so that they can open up that
email okay
so uh we'll just say have any good day
we can make it better just as an example
something that's gonna be
attention grabbing if you will okay you
can always tweak the subject line
in fact my advice is always do a b
testing on the subject line so you can
do two different
subject lines with one email to figure
out which one has better open rates
and then with mailchimp we can go ahead
and design the content
of our email so we're gonna click design
email okay we can
select a template we have some save
templates already
okay or we can go with a theme
so mailchimp has a lot of good offers
now there's a lot of different
email platforms out there i particularly
like mailchimp because
of this very feature they have a lot of
good themes here
um a lot of different layouts that you
can use okay
so you know we're gonna showcase that
product
okay and that's the template we're going
to use here so here we go
we're going to showcase our product
we're going to add that photo of our
product here
and we're going to go ahead and put some
nice messaging in here
with some nice call to action we can put
our logo up here for branding again we
can
edit the content here so based on that
segmented list
in this example for linda's company
maybe she wants to target those folks
who bought her moisturizer before her
face moisturizer and she wants to
retarget them
she wants to go ahead and say hey you
guys have bought my product before check
out this
new face moisturizer that we have to
offer so whatever the case is you want
to be able to plan that out ahead of
time you want to be able to plan
out who your audience is you want to
plan out your messaging
and you want to go ahead and set up the
messaging
based on that audience so once you have
the messaging in place
voila you're more or less ready to go
okay so
once you get the content all set up
you can schedule that campaign okay and
you can
also add a social post to your campaign
so we can share that information
on social so email integrates nicely
with social media
so again that's that's pretty much what
you need to do here you need to really
think about who it is you want to target
choose those recipients
okay customize it and make it personal
create a good subject line in fact
create two subject lines
and then align that content with that
audience okay that's that's really the
checklist here
so again we look at this checklist
creating our list
who do we want to send the email to so
we added our contacts to the list
we set up the campaign we selected the
list
we chose the format we modified it with
a good subject line
with some good messaging and then we're
going to schedule that email campaign
so that's the checklist to go off okay
so remember identify target audience and
create segments
then you create that campaign and in our
case we did set an appropriate call to
action
you know get shopping basically we want
people to shop our new moisturizer
key thing here is before we send it out
we want to test that email
once everything looks good we're going
to i would advise schedule it but you
can always send the email when you're
ready
i would schedule it at the appropriate
time and day
okay so in this case you don't want to
send an email out on a friday afternoon
okay when people are getting ready for
the weekend you certainly don't want to
send an email out over the weekend
because
you're not going to have many people
look and open it and you probably don't
want to send the email out on a monday
morning when most people are
getting into the office from a long
weekend and
catching up on emails so from my
experience
you know tuesday wednesday depending on
your time zone i would always say
you know late morning early afternoon
tends to be a good time but
that's why we have performance that's
why we can analyze performance we want
to be able to see what the open rates
are and the click-through rates are so
that we can make adjustments for future
emails so let's talk about
some of those metrics so when you do
send that email
you know we're going to look at that
open so open rate is the percentage of
the total number of recipients who open
an email so okay so if we basically
you know send it to x amount of people
minus those emails that have bounced so
let's just say
you know we sent it to a hundred and two
people
okay for simplicity's sake two of those
emails bounced
okay so that means that we've had a
hundred net
100 emails that received the email and
let's just say 75
open the email okay we wrote such a good
subject line
that they opened it okay that's 75
percent that's a 75
open rate that's how you measure open
rate click through rate okay so if they
open
it we hope that they click on something
and so
for all of those emails that were
delivered okay in this case a hundred
how many actually did click on our call
to action so
let's just say 75 opened it
out of the 100 that's a 75 open rate but
of the 100 that actually were delivered
let's just say
we had 25 that actually clicked
on the call to action and so that's 25
okay and so you want to be able to
measure not only who
opens it but who clicks on the call to
action so that's click-through rate for
email marketing
and then response rate so it's the
percentage of the total recipients
who clicked on a link of your email
campaign and actually completed the
action
so in our example we're trying to get
people to click on the shopping call to
action
and get them to purchase so we sent 100
emails
and of the 25 who actually clicked
we had 10 who actually took action and
purchase
so 10 divided by 100 is 10
so you have open rate click-through rate
and response rate those are some
key metrics for email marketing okay the
first step is you got to get people to
open it that's where the subject line
is so important click their way that's
where the messaging and call to action
is so important we want to get people to
click on that call to action
and then the response rate we want them
to buy so those are our three key
metrics related to email marketing
so let's take a look at an example if we
go back to our email marketing platform
mailchimp in this example we're going to
take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms
have reporting functionality built in
and so in this case
what we want to do is we want to be able
to take a look at the open rate
click-through rates
of the emails that have been sent out
previously so
here we could see our april email coupon
versus tools promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens
and clicks so 14 open rate
1.4 click-through rate okay so
the march email that went out did a
little bit better
19 open two and a half percent on the
click-through rate
so here we could see how many people
actually
were sent how many open it and how many
clicks so this is a mailchimp makes it
very
easy for us to measure you know open and
click rates
and then we can measure by revenue as
well based
on the campaign so that's
measuring the response rate so it's all
built in
so most email marketing platforms have
open rate and click
rate already built into the
functionality so you can measure
those two metrics against any email
so let's talk about the benefits of
email marketing
so what are some of the benefits well
we've already mentioned to linda
that it's cost effective it's time
saving
real time marketing less intrusive
builds credibility
increases visibility and brand awareness
and it's an easy way to track roi
these are all the benefits for email
marketing we're gonna go
talk about some of these now so
basically when we talk about
cost effective you know some email
marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me to set up
that email campaign
the key is figuring out who you want to
send it to when we talk about real-time
marketing you know we're sending this
email out basically in real time
trying to meet our customers needs at
the right time
it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can
as you saw i can put first name in there
to make it more
personal so when something's more
personal it's less intrusive
especially if it's a segment that
already knows your brand
okay builds credibility hey we gain
credibility
when we offer exclusive offers to repeat
customers or
you know try and build advocacy by
working with non-profits
okay it increases visibility and brand
awareness why
because you know we could send our email
out to
a large group of people and that's a
good way to
generate brand awareness and as you saw
we can easily measure
you know not only open rates click rates
but roi
so how many people from that email went
on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email
so let's move into a b testing so a b
testing is key to email marketing okay
so
in email marketing gaining high open
rates and click-through rates will
result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory
that's what's supposed to happen we get
more opens we get more people to click
we get more people to click we're gonna
get more people to purchase
okay but it's not as easy as it sounds
so how do we make that possible well
we're gonna do that
via a b testing i've already mentioned
it when i set up my example
campaign in mailchimp i stressed and
stressed
and stressed that we need to have two
subject lines
go out per email okay so before
i stress that again let me just
reiterate what a b
testing is and a b testing is a method
to analyze
which of the two email campaign
strategies most effective
in terms of high open rates and click
rates okay so in this case
an a b test you can send out two emails
you can send out two subject lines
you can send out two call to actions
you're just really what you're doing is
you're testing
one against the other that's what a b
testing is and so
in my example i talked about that
subject line so for better results a b
testing can be done with the subject
line can also be done with the email
content
so the subject line impacts the open
rate okay so i wrote a subject line i
don't even know how that subject line is
going to perform
but if i write a second subject line
then
i'll be able to basically give myself a
better chance of getting a better open
rate because i'm offering up
two different subject lines likewise for
email content
so the subject line and email content
are the most important elements
so we want to be able to test them if
they're interesting intriguing
uh attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates
if the content itself is interesting
engaging
a good offer good call to action then
the click rates are going to be
increased so we want to be able to serve
up variations for
our audience so we want to consider an
example of an a b
test where linda has set up two
variations
of the email campaign as an example so
she's gonna
send two different subject lines to test
which one
generates more open rates because that's
what subject line
a b testing is going to do one of them
is going to have a higher open rate okay
so in our example here linda sends
version a
of the email to 50 of the recipients
with the subject line three important
strategies to increase your open rate
well
version b which is sent to the other 50
has the subject line three important
strategies to increase
your open rate so the only difference
here is
three and three the number three spelled
out well
because she sent out two different
subject lines she's going to now
be able to measure the success of that a
b test
okay and it just so happens version a
has a higher open rate
number numbers always tend to work in
subject lines by the way
so linda sends version a of the email to
fifty percent
of the recipients okay eighty dollars
today but ninety dollars tomorrow
and version b to the remaining fifty
percent eighty dollars today
ninety dollars tomorrow and the only
really succinct difference here
is using the word but versus a comma and
she sent that email
out and that email went out and the date
is coming in and she's going to measure
the success of that a b
test well version b has the higher open
rate
you know we want to be short succinct
and stay away from those conjugations
like but
okay it tends to have a negative
connotation so
the shorter more direct email our
subject line 80
today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
high open rates another example here
version a
again gets 50 with the subject line
uh-oh
your prescription is expiring version b
your prescription is expiring you folks
listen to this webinar right now i
wonder
which one you think will perform go
ahead and put your comments
right below this video i'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open so
let's go ahead and measure the success
of the a b
test okay so she sent the email out two
different subject lines
fifty percent got one subject line the
other fifty percent got the other
subject line
and it just so happens version a
uh oh your prescription is expiring
there's a little bit of
a you know personalization to that you
know for me
your prescription is expiring seems to
be a little bit more
you know command-ish hey your com
prescription is expiring so we expect
you to purchase where you have a little
uh oh in front
it's like hey you know i think your
prescription is expiring
maybe you should think about renewing it
okay i think that's how that's
interpreted at least that's how i
interpret it so i would probably go
ahead and click on that email
with that subject line so you could see
subtle differences
in the subject lines make a big
difference in open rates
so in order to keep improving those open
rates you need to continue
and not continue should always do
subject line
testing always because one subject line
is always going to have a better open
rate than the other
so always do a b testing when it comes
to subject lines
and email content for that matter okay
so
we're always going to do continuous a b
testing so with continuous a b
testing we can test very various
elements of the email
so you can always test the sender's name
the subject line the copy the call to
action
the design the imagery there's a lot of
different elements
you can test with emails for example
center's name okay so you wanna
personalize it as much as you can okay
you don't want to do a no reply you want
it to come from a human being
in this case sam okay at least that's
what i think let's see what the
test states no surprise version a
has the higher open rate if you
customize these things and personalize
them
then it goes a long way sending an email
from a no reply is not a good
best practice let's talk about
the subject line again uh so we got
webinar
increase your email open rates webinar
increase your email open rates
so the webinar is dynamic on version a
okay so we're sending that out and
because it's dynamic
that's going to you know beat out the
static
webinar increase your email open rates a
lot more elements we can test here
so for example the email copy so learn
some easy ways to increase your email
open rates join us on may 10
2019 7 pm for an interactive discussion
with our experts
well version b is more personalized it's
a same message
but we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case
rachel so we can measure the success of
the a b
test but it's no surprise that anything
that's customized
that comes from somebody a name you know
with a dynamic
email subject line is going to perform
better it's going to increase
open rates and it's going to increase
click rates so
we can also test that call to action the
difference here
is coloring save my seat yellow versus
save my c
blue again go ahead and play along here
if you're watching this go ahead and add
a comment and just see if you're right
do you think it's blue or you think it's
yellow on the call to action
color does go a long way in email
marketing so let's measure the success
of this a b
test and it just so happens yellow is
going to perform better why does yellow
perform better than blue
what's more positive plus it it kind of
resonates a little bit stronger
and easier okay it stands out a little
bit better
it's not as pastely and dull as this
shade of blue we're using
so you can see here we're testing every
bit of the elements of the email
anything from the from
to the subject line to the message to
the call to action
and so at the end of the day you know
you want to be able to
send out the best email that's going to
give you the best results
so we're going to send that out the
entirety of the email
and we could see version a looks a lot
better and why does version a look a lot
better in this example because
look at the font size is a little bit
bigger
version b font size smaller harder to
read that's another thing you can test
larger fonts tend to do a little bit
better now you don't want to go
overboard and have them
you know 48 points or 50 points and plus
you know 14 versus 12 goes a long way
we can continue testing we can test
imagery
you can see here we have a hand aligned
with the call to action
they just look different that's all
version a has one
type of hand version b as the other type
of hand align with the call to action
let's go ahead and send out that test
and see what works
well version b works why the hand stands
out a little bit more clear it doesn't
blend in
with the call to action so you can see
we're testing different elements here
and we're always
improving and adding to what's working
so we started out with
a no reply versus somebody's name
then we move to a subject line then we
move to personalization
then we move to you know call to action
then we move to an increased font
meaning the design
and then we're adding imagery so we're
constantly improving the email
with each test eventually you're going
to get to a point where
you know the email is going to be good
and you're going to just continue to
test
different options on it to continue to
increase
open rates click rates and response
rates
final output looks like this again that
personalized email
response from sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice dynamic subject
line
gotta personalize the email to rachel
with larger font
okay we got a nice call to action that
stands out
with a nice image to accompany that so
we've tested all these different
elements this is the best
combination based on everything we
tested so when we get that email to go
this is what it's going to look like
in the future but guess what we're not
going to stop testing
so we can continue to test those subject
lines continue to test the messaging and
continue to test the email design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images
you're never going to stop testing with
email marketing
okay so let's switch over to how to
optimize
the subject line subject line is such a
key component to email marketing
so as we showed you in the last segment
we tested a subject line
and we used a number the number three
versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line your emails come a long way emojis
aren't just
social media based you can use emojis in
subject lines i'd highly recommend it
you know i just sat
on an email last month with the subject
line about
you know spring showers bring may
flowers and guess what emoji i had in
that subject line
a flower okay may sound cheesy but it
goes a long way
so according to experian subject lines
with emojis can increase
open rates by 45 people resonate with
emojis especially if they're
positive emojis okay so we want to
personalize those subject lines for
better
open rate okay when i say personalize
don't be so stale
remember that subject line we tested uh
oh just putting
uh oh in there made it sound like we
actually cared it was a little bit
personal it wasn't so personal you
weren't dressing a specific
person but one little word goes a long
way in a subject line because when
people get emails and they read emails
and a lot of people are inundated with
emails
the subject line is what they're reading
first and just by personalizing it
adding a number adding an emoji just
making it positive and easy to read
they're likely to open that email so
personalized email messages
can improve click through rate and open
rates as well
so you want to personalize your email as
much as you can
whether that be from the from field to
putting that person's name
in the salutation so personalized
subject lines have been found to
increase
open rates by up to 50 percent so don't
come across as spammy
come across as you know who your
audience is and you're talking to them
and then you want to prefer title case
subject lines
so title case subject lines for example
when i say title case
game of thrones is my favorite show
every
initial letter in that title is
capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case
game of thrones is my favorite show it
doesn't stand out as much of course if
you go with lowercase
it definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and
somebody's probably not going to open it
so you always go with that title case
the
every initial letter gets capitalized so
how to optimize that subject line well
watch the length of your subject line
you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters
you want to keep it short succinct and
to the point but personalized with an
emoji with initial caps
on each word to make it stand out but
you have to do that within 17
17 and 24 characters so according to
campaign monitor
the ideal length of a subject line is up
to 24 characters
and they're more likely to boost those
email rates okay so
keep it short but make it impactful make
it personalized like i mentioned before
if you get too long then it may get cut
off and it may not
have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why
we always recommend keeping it up to
about 24 characters okay if you go over
by a couple characters not the end of
the world
but try and stay within that range
develop a sense of
urgency okay so when we say sense of
urgency
we mean sense of urgency meaning if that
coupon is going to expire
you know you want to let people know
it's going to expire that day or the
next day or within a few days
okay so you can use things like hurry up
or limit offer
or limited stock or offer expires on
okay so add a bit of sense of urgency i
mean
sky is not falling here but if that
coupon's expiring
at the end of the week you probably want
to mention something
to the effect of hey offers expiring or
hurry up
so let's talk about optimizing your
email content so we focused a lot on
subject lines let's talk about the email
content itself
so some ways to optimize email content
are we want to send the content that is
relevant to
customer expectations so content needs
to match that expectation
we want to use bullet points to make the
content readable
we want to follow logical structure we
want to use compelling imagery
and prefer design emails with responsive
designs and what we mean by responsive
design is hey
most people are going to be checking
that email on their mobile phone
okay so make sure when you design the
email
it's also going to be good not just on
desktop but on tablet and mobile as well
and then of course just goes without
saying but avoid grammatical mistakes
go ahead and spell checked it and that's
why we put an emphasis on
testing your email before you actually
send it and when you actually
send an email test email don't send it
to yourself
send it to colleagues you know send it
to another group a fresh set of eyes
a fresh set of eyes like it's going to
be able to pick out
that misspelled word that you overlooked
so
i can't stress the sending of the test
email because
it's going to be able to you know in a
way
ensure that you're doing everything on
this list in addition to grammatical
mistakes
you know the person who's receiving your
test email your colleague at work
may be looking at that email on their
mobile phone and if it doesn't look good
to them
they're going to let you know some other
ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the a
b testing you always want to personalize
it
question is hey do i use first name do i
use first and last name
well guess what you can test that but
you want to personalize it okay you want
to choose the right fonts and colors for
your email
so when we were going through some
examples on testing
you know i always tend to go a little
bit larger on the font but you can play
around with it
i don't think you should probably use
white lettering on a black
background that just is not very
good or best practice but go ahead and
try it if you want okay you can always
play around and test these
but you want to choose something that's
really going to resonate
with the recipient of the email okay you
want to build a rapport with customers
by
sharing insights they value for example
the beginning of this webinar we talked
about advocacy we talked about
you know sharing with them some of the
non-profits that
we work with as a company okay if we
have a
you know cosmetics company and we have
different products like moisturizers and
facial creams
we may want to state that hey we don't
use
any animals in the testing of these
products you know we're pro
animal we're not you know we're not
going to use animals in the testing of
our products
and that probably resonates with a lot
of your customers so you want to
go ahead and build a rapport with those
customers by sharing those insights
okay and use recipient names and you
always want to
personalize it then add a clear call to
action at the end you always want to
have that call to action
regardless of what the email is hey it
could be just a simple
read more or hey donate it doesn't have
to always be so hardcore
in terms of hey purchase our product
that could be a turn off especially if
you're sending emails out
once a week to your customer base
they're constantly hammering them
with buy now buy now buy now they're
going to get turned off so you want to
mix
up the call to actions and that goes
back to the very first step
and what kind of email are you going to
send out and who are you going to send
it to so you have to align those two but
somebody who doesn't even know who your
brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of buy now
you're probably going to say hey check
us out we have some cool stuff for you
okay let's talk about
automating emails email automation so
triggered emails are sent to customers
based on an event date or user behavior
okay so when we say
an event could be a special occasion
like mother's day
okay could be a date like a birthday or
anniversary or specific day of the week
could also be based on user behavior you
know a good example of user behavior are
those who abandon the car
you can trigger an email in fact
mailchimp has remarketing
functionality so with mailchimp hey if
somebody abandons our car
we can have an email triggered and we
could send an email a nice email that
says hey we noticed you
didn't finish purchasing our product and
i'm not sure what happened but hey
here's another 10 off or you can always
just make product recommendations as
well
but you want to react to user behavior
and use
emails to your advantage for that so you
want to take be cognizant of
different occasions you want to be
cognizant of special events
holidays etc and user behavior so these
types of emails can be automated because
you know when they might happen
or that they are probably going to
happen so auto responder emails are sent
at frequent intervals
based on the behavior of subscribers so
for example if somebody purchases
something
then you're gonna get an email that
probably says hey
thank you for your purchase another
email that says hey your products on its
way
and then another email that says hey
your package your product has been
delivered
so that's an example of an automated
email that goes out if somebody
purchases your product you probably want
to thank them for that
and then you probably want to let them
know that hey it's on its way
here you could track it and then again
you want to confirm that it's been
delivered but thank them again
so that's an example of an automated
email that goes out
okay let's talk about types of email
campaigns
so we have different types of email
campaigns
and the first is a newsletter so with
email newsletters subscribers are
connected and informed about product
updates
so it doesn't necessarily have to be a
product they buy
it could be a product they subscribe to
like software
okay you always want to be able to send
out that newsletter to let them know
what's going on
with your product are there upcoming
product updates ahead
is there one that just happened is there
a webinar that discusses
the new product update so that's what
the newsletter is going to do inform
the end user about the update so how to
optimize
okay so you stack your email content
create a compelling header
share different variety of useful
content like videos articles etc
with those recipients and then follow a
consistent schedule so
that's how you handle a newsletter you
should always create a compelling header
but if you're going to send a newsletter
make sure you support it with some good
information like a video that they can
go watch or an article that
will follow up on what you put in the
email or
promoting that webinar that's going to
talk about that product update
so example here is a newsletter that
gets sent
out and here you can see it talks about
business process
it's got some nice imagery in there okay
call to action
it's got a little bit of everything in
this email template okay
and that's when we talk about stack your
email content that's what you talk about
stacking
you can see at the top it's got work
with the industry best
subscribe now okay they validate that
with 25 years of top notch service
then they talk about hiring the best
talent and you got the next bit of
content below that so that's stacked
email content okay that's going to be
supported by compelling header
and then they're going to share a
variety of different content in there
like there could be clicks in there to
video videos and articles
moving on from newsletters to
promotional emails so we want to be able
to drive revenue by
sending special offers through
promotional email
okay so how do we optimize a promotional
email
well we want to personalize the campaign
okay promotional we want to definitely
personalize it
include time sensitive offers we want to
get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title
and the subject line okay you can send
offer emails on holidays if it's
mother's day
hey send it a couple days before or even
send it on
if it's personalized then you can say
hey so and so
we know you're a mother here take 20 off
i mean that kind of
personalized email with an offer goes a
long way here you
an example from toms limited time extra
20
off all styles they include the code in
there
okay again you can see the the
sensitivity
and the sense of urgency with the
limited time
another email campaign type and
personally one of my favorites is
abandoned cart
so abandon card emails i like working
with abandoned card emails cause
you know we want people to purchase and
as much as you try on your email
marketing campaign to drive
traffic to the website and as hard as
the website works to get people to
convert
through the shopping cart it's never
gonna be a hundred percent
and so abandoned cart emails give us
that extra incentive to get that person
back to the shopping cart to purchase
okay so these emails are shared with
customers who have added
product to their cart but didn't finish
through the checkout process in other
words they didn't
purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it gives
us another opportunity to reach out to
that person
who just is almost there but not quite
ready to finish the purchase so what are
we going to do we're going to send out
an email for those that abandon their
car and we're going to use a simple
abandoned cart email template okay you
want to be simple here
you don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish
purchasing the products and we want to
definitely personalize it
okay we want to send a series of email
reminders
okay in your email reminder add a
product image
so as customized as it can be it could
be
even the product image of what they've
abandoned and that's the best practice
so if it's that facial moisturizer that
linda's trying to promote and she can't
quite
get enough people to finish purchasing
the product they're
they're banning the cart well she can
certainly send out the abandoned cart
email
okay so for example you want to
personalize it
hey you forgot to complete your order
you left something in your car can we
help
email too hi there so and so items in
your shopping cart are selling out
quickly
it's a gentle reminder okay so come
across a little bit different here
okay email three hey so-and-so twenty
percent off on your car
valid until so-and-so offer on your
favorite product
so the first email that went out and the
series of emails
hey you forgot something hey is there
anything we can do to help you
complete the product purchase email too
is just that gentle reminder hey
you're selling out quickly you might
want to purchase that product
and the email three is to really help
them along by saying hey
here's 20 off valid until so and so
so just a small series of emails that go
out
try and get somebody back into the
shopping cart
okay let's talk about re-engagement
campaign so
in a re-engagement campaign it's a
series of emails sent to
inactive email subscribers so what it
does is it boosts engagement and helps
to maintain a high
inbox placement ratio inbox placement
ratio so we want to be able to
make sure that we're getting people back
on our subscriber list
so how are we going to optimize for
something like this this is
now these are difficult type of email
campaigns we're trying to re-engage with
people who are inactive
so we want gamification to re-engage
subscribers or
we want to prefer subject lines like hey
we've been missing you
or did we do something wrong okay we can
run a poll or
competition to re-engage with our
subscribers so for example
hey we'd hate to miss your birthday go
ahead and update your account this is a
starbucks
email so we'd hate to miss your birthday
so
it's that you know message of missing
you you can always
soften or sweeten the deal with an offer
as well
so that brings us to how to engage with
new subscribers
so we just talked about re-engaging with
inactive
we want to talk about engaging with new
subscribers so how to engage with new
subscribers well
thank your subscribers for joining okay
create
clear and compelling subject lines that
is a must regardless of what type of
email you send out you
always want to send out that compelling
subject line
okay we noticed the good examples within
17 to 24 characters know the ideal time
to message okay again sending it on the
weekends not gonna work
okay sending it out during the weekday
you know
in the morning mid morning you know
sometimes in the afternoon works
really depends on who your audience is
but weekends probably aren't going to
work okay
avoid the no reply center name again
personalize it you're either sam or rob
or so and so sally
you know let them know that the email's
coming from a real person
okay because if it doesn't come from a
person most people aren't going to
respond
okay we want to let our subscribers know
the privacy policy
so we want to let them know that we
abide by
a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you straight with people who are
new they don't know your brand they
don't know your privacy policy
they don't want to get spammed in other
words so putting that out there
makes you more transparent and
trustworthy okay and again
personalization always personalized if
it's new
if it's inactive repeat customers loyal
customers lifetime
customers you should always personalize
and you should always be courteous
and always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay work with
something that's going to be eye catchy
and then most important most important
is
include an unsubscribe link i can't
tell you how annoying it is to get an
email
and not have the unsubscribe link there
that makes me
want to unsubscribe even if it was a
good email
i still look for that because maybe
they're good company but they're
spamming me they're sending me too many
emails so maybe i want to unsubscribe or
change my subscription
so you always want to include that
unsubscribed link in fact in the united
states it's actually law
so there is regulation about that around
that so you need to
include an unsubscribe link it's just
common courtesy
if anything so it bodes well okay of
course you don't want people to
unsubscribe
but you don't want them to get annoyed
either okay let's talk about email
marketing tools
so we talked about mailchimp so there
are plenty of email marketing platforms
out there
i use mailchimp i've used a few in the
past
like marketo i've used zoho vertical
response
so there are a lot of different tools
out there here some of them
again mailchimp marketo marketo is a
marketing automation tool or system and
marketo is good for sending those
automated emails hubspot
convertkit send in blue aweber i mean
these are just
some of the many that are out there okay
so let's show a demo again
of an email marketing campaign so
let's show an example of a newsletter
that
one of my clients had sent out and so
this is paul ekman group paul ekman dr
ekman
inspired the tv show lie to me so well
known
in the industry of micro expressions
he's the aforementioned
expert in micro expressions and he sends
out email marketing campaigns
and he sends out a monthly newsletter so
this is a
newsletter was sent out in november
2018. and if we look at it
you can see here okay it's stacked
content nice imagery
okay respectful disagreements how to
deal with disagreements
this holiday season so really relevant
personalized because and timely because
it was set in november
during the holiday season so got some
nice imagery there
okay we got content in here and then
right below that on the stack content
what do we have
final hour 24 hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built in
to the email then here you go you have
some other
content in there based on the face of
contempt
okay just an example of a micro
expression
and then right below that what do we see
we see a call to action
learn how to use microexpressions to
your advantage so
call to action here then we have some
more
information here with the learn more so
a newsletter that went out
basically a blog post built into the
email with some nice content
reminding folks hey they have 24 hours
got some other
useful information in the email so
this email went out very timely 98
000 okay see subject line here
controversy respectful disagreements and
thanksgiving
okay could the subject line be a little
bit shorter yes
possibly but if we look at the open rate
15
16 open rate okay industry average
in education and trainings 18 okay so
they're close to the industry
average on the click rate you know 1.6
percent on the click rate
industry average 2.1 so we can see
what the top links were clicked okay so
they have a lot of links and
and mailchimp will help you measure what
links were clicked the most
who subscribed what subscriber with the
most opens
we can see opens by country but that's
an example of a newsletter
for this particular company okay stacked
content
okay sense of urgency okay you can see
the subject line
timely newsletter so this is a
a good i think a good example of an
email
for the time of year okay so let's go
over the checklist again
for email marketing so good reminders on
the checklist this is a checklist
you want to make sure all boxes are
checked
you want to create interesting subject
lines
as they boost your open rates direct
correlation with open rates is subject
line okay you
want to keep your content relevant and
consistent with your brand
you want to check the sender name okay
so you want to make sure
not only is it personalized but the name
aligns with the email address
okay you should always personalize
always personalize the subject line
and the email copy text meaning you know
don't just say hello
say hello to sally pete rob
michael etc always include an
unsubscribe
link in emails and give people the
option to unsubscribe
okay you can always re-engage them
another way or later on but you don't
want to irk
any one of your potential customers use
a b
testing we talked about a b testing the
webinar there's lots of different
elements we can test from
subject line to content to font to call
to action
to imagery to subject line etc there's
no
shortage of elements in an email you can
test you want to use welcome
emails to build good customer
relationships so when somebody signs up
for a newsletter
send out a welcome news uh email to them
hey welcome
thank you for signing up you should
always
segment your list based on user behavior
so
you have a group of people who purchase
product a customize your email for
product a
but you know you can mention product b
and c in there
but know who your audience is so you can
talk to your audience
okay and you can always ask your
subscribers to update their preferences
as well because you want to make sure
you're sending out emails to the right
person right address
okay this is a short checklist now we
can expand upon this but these are some
of the
most of the key items when it comes to
email marketing
some other items on the checklist
include features such as countdown
timers and live polls
okay make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency
don't be sending emails three or four
times a week
once a week is probably as much as you
want to go
depending on what it is if somebody
purchases something
then you probably want to send an email
thanking them for the purchase
another one letting another product has
been shipped
and another one with thank you the
product has
been received reward those subscribers
send out exclusive offers okay make sure
your emails are optimized for mobile
that means
send out test emails and check it on
different devices okay create a schedule
okay you can automate these emails so
create a schedule
that makes the most sense have a footer
and header in the email
and in that footer and header is going
to be some information
okay just like i showed you with the
microexpressions
there was a footer and header avoid spam
filters
okay how do you avoid spam filters well
apply best practices
and don't have spammy subject lines have
an
actual name associated with the reply to
email
and and split up your list as well when
you send out one email
to 150 000 people it could probably get
caught up in some spam
so segment out your audiences keep your
audience list short so that your
messaging
can be specific to the audience that's
going to help avoid spam
and then of course you always want to
measure and analyze results
so remember a lot of these email
marketing platforms
have the results built in especially
open rates
and click rates we're going to talk
about
mailchimp so we're going to go through
the features and benefits of using
mailchimp azure email content platform
so buckle up and let's get started with
mailchimp
so the first thing you need to do is
sign up for an account
with mailchimp and that's simply just
providing an
email address an id and a password and i
recommend when you actually sign up for
an account
you sign up with the free plan first and
let's take a look at
what the feature plan features are for
mailchimp
so i'm recommending the free plan but
when you actually sign up
you have the option to actually pay for
a plan
so you have the essential the standard
the premium or the free
and so i recommend you go with the free
version first it's like
buying a car you want to test drive it
out see if you like it see if you like
the features and benefits
and you can see here that with the free
plan you get a lot of features and
benefits so you get all the basics
for businesses that are just getting
started so if you're just getting
started with email marketing
i would recommend the free plan here
because you have a 2
000 contact maximum so that means you
can send out an email to
your 2 000 recipients free of charge so
not a bad deal
for businesses who are starting out i
mean if you
are prepared you've used mailchimp
before then go ahead
and sign up for one of the paid versions
each version
has a different set of standards a
different set of features and benefits
from the essential all the way up to the
premium where you're gonna get
you know advanced features um and more
customization
but that's 299 dollars a month so if
you're not prepared to pay that amount
then my recommendation start with that
free plan now when you actually do
set up your account you're just gonna
again provide a
id email address and password you're
gonna go through a couple of steps and
one of these steps that i would
recommend you do right away
is connect your facebook and twitter
accounts so if you already have a
facebook and twitter account very simple
all you're doing is authorizing
mailchimp to connect to the account
and the reason for that is when you
actually connect your twitter facebook
account
you'll be able to then you know share
content on those platforms
and mailchimp will do that for you
automatically okay so
here you're just asking it to more or
less interact with the platform social
platform and i recommended doing that
as you're going through the setup
process very simple to do
if you're already logged into your
twitter facebook account
all you need to do is click on the plus
button as you go through the
setup wizard and authorize mailchimp to
access your twitter or facebook account
here you can see
what mailchimp's going to be able to do
they're going to be able to retweets
from your timeline
post tweets for you on your behalf if
you want them to
if you want them to you're going to
allow mailchimp to see create and manage
your advertising data including the
campaigns and audiences
and the reason for this is you may
you know want to integrate your email
marketing efforts
with your social media efforts and the
great thing about mailchimp is
hey look if you want to post content on
these platforms you'll be able to
if you want to leverage other benefits
from facebook and twitter and integrate
them
with mailchimp you'll be able to so
having these two platforms in the case
of facebook and twitter talk to
mailchimp is
a positive because then you'll be able
to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so i highly recommend you take
this as a necessary step when you're
going through the setup now it's
optional you don't have to but i
recommend it
now when you're actually setting up your
account you're going to be asked to
you know design a template okay so you
could pick a template
just by default you could pick one just
to get the account going but you can
always go back
and add or change out the template so
here you can see i'm in the setup wizard
but i
arbitrarily just chose a template i can
go back and choose some of the templates
that are available to me
now again you can create your own
template if you want to okay
so you just click create template and
you'll be you know asked to choose kind
of a
you know template that you can pretty
much change
and customize so if you're thinking
about sending out an email
with an announcement then that's the
type of template you want to
choose and so here now you can see we
have a logo
we can change the announcement here we
can add
photos etc so if i want to add my logo
i'm just going to go up to this top
portion here click the little
pencil icon that allows me to edit here
you can see its default logo i don't
really have a logo so i can say replace
it
i can also link to it and here you can
see
in the content studio of mailchimp i
don't have any images to choose from so
i'm going to go ahead and upload one
and i'm going to go ahead and upload my
logo that i've had on my desktop
okay so it's going to upload and now i
can select
that and insert it so now i have my logo
as part of my template here
and you can also see you can add some
styling here
to this header part so i can add a nice
border around that
okay so i can align its center i can go
edge to edge
okay so i can customize the image
in this particular template here so i'm
just going to click save and close
now i'm ready to move on to the next
part which is just
click on edit i want to make an
announcement okay
share your big news okay we're having
a launch party okay so here you can see
again just in this template this
quote-unquote announcement template
i'm able to just make changes to each
section now i'm in the section of the
announcement part
where i can now customize the text
and you can see i can you know bold it
you know i can choose a different font
go ariel i can choose the size you can
make it smaller larger
pretty easy to use i could again style
it with different color
and so i can make multiple columns here
if i want to
so there's a lot you can do just in this
one section as well
so let's go ahead and just do one more
thing here
that's maybe color or something i mean
you can see i can add a link
let's go ahead and make it blue that's
the background so i want to change the
background
so i'm just going to click ctrl z i'll
change the color
of the font itself there you go very
simple and easy to use
now i can add photos here if i want to
so let's go ahead and edit this bottom
part here so i'm going to click
again the edit icon okay so here you can
see i have three images in the template
i'm gonna go ahead and add to that so
here i can go ahead
and upload some files so i have some
files waiting for me on my desktop i'm
just gonna go ahead and add them
and upload them to the content studio
and
now that i've uploaded them i can select
one of them
to insert okay now i'm going to go here
insert the second one
and now i'm going to grab the third one
and insert that
in its place here you can see now i can
go ahead and
you know style each one of these if i
want to okay i can add a border again
okay i can go ahead and do rounded
corners okay
settings you can see how i can set it up
this so they're all vertical i can do
this
so i have a lot of flexibility
in what i add to these particular
you know templates okay this is again
just the announcement template
and so now i'm going to click save and
close and
here you can see i can add some other
things to it if i wanted to i could play
around with the design and header
and once i'm done really if i'm happy
with my email i can just close it out
and i'm done so what i could do now is
when you're done with this template
you can just preview and test it so i
could send a test email or
enter preview mode so if i enter preview
mode this is what the template i chose
is going to look like if i happen to
send it out
okay this is what it looks like on
desktop this is what it looks like a
mobile
and if i go inbox preview i'll need to
upgrade my account because
i'm on the free version so but i could
certainly
see what it looks like on mobile on
desktop so i'm just going to click out
of that
and this is a template and so i can go
back
and edit this anytime i want so when i'm
done i'm just going to go ahead and
click
the mailchimp icon in the upper left
it's going to ask me to
name my template so i'm going to name
this the announcement template
i'm going to click save and now it's in
my templates
so i'm free to use this template
anytime i'm ready to send an email okay
and again i can
you saw how easy it was to make a change
in the template itself so when i'm ready
to use the template i can just go ahead
and grab it okay and again
i can go ahead and style it and design
it any way i want
so you have different sections of the
page that you can style
and here you got you know mobile style
designs if you wanted to
now if you wanted to in the template if
i want to like duplicate the whole block
i can duplicate that whole block and you
can see it just copied it or i can just
get rid of it
to very easy to use wysiwyg if you will
or interface
it allows you mailchimp allows from some
easy
you know functionality easy features to
go ahead and manipulate and change to
your liking okay so again
i'm working with a template here so
anytime i'm ready to use that template
for an email i can go in and start using
it
okay and if i go to templates again i'm
gonna find my template here
i can always edit it i can always share
it
i can always preview it i can replicate
it and that's the important thing so if
i replicate it
i'm basically creating a copy of it okay
so i just created a copy
so now if i wanted to create a or change
the copy of it
i can do that so if i don't like this
whole block i can just delete it
and now that i'm done i can rename this
i'm just going to say
announcement template v2 so now it's
been renamed
and now i have two templates just simply
by choosing one
and replicating it so again if i go back
to templates here
here i go i have my two templates and i
can store these in a folder so i'm going
to add a folder i'm going to call it
announcements
and i'm going to add the folder and
that's it so
now i can store these in the folder so
you can organize
all your templates in different folders
if you want to so i'm going to take
these
two templates here move them to my
announcements folder
and there you go they're in the
announcements folder so if you're going
to create multiple templates then i
would recommend
you go ahead and organize it create
folders
you know and set up as many folders as
you want and need
because you're going to probably have
different templates
for different occasions depends on what
type of email you're sending out so i
just chose arbitrarily
an announcement type email so now if i
go back to create templates
okay you can see again let's go through
some of these others again i just chose
make an announcement you could tell a
story
follow-up educate you got all sorts of
different templates that you could
choose
all sorts and here you got some themes
so you can even go
with a theme if you wanted to so for
example
if you're selling products let's just
say you have a boutique store let's just
choose this boutique template if i
choose this
here is my themed template and so now
just like the other template i was
working in i can go ahead and edit this
here you can see at the top i got the
middle section
you know i got all these different
sections that i can now go ahead and
edit
so just about really it's about choosing
the theme
template that works best for you and
feel free to
you know try these different templates
out and see what works best for you
so here you can add in certain things
like you know social share so if i just
drag and drop i can add in a social
share
image card so a lot of these themes are
very flexible in what you can do
in terms of the design in terms of the
content so again
if you go back and i'm going to cancel
and not save this temp well let's save
it we'll call it boutique
we may use it again in the future so i'm
going to go ahead and click
save and now it's a template it's going
to be located in templates
and again if you always want to access
templates just go to templates you'll
see the templates that you already
have created and edited so you can edit
them always just by clicking the edit
button
now that's again if you want to create a
new template just create
click on the create new template call to
action again you got themes
you've got layouts or you can even
create your own from scratch
you can import another template that you
created in another
email marketing platform or you could do
simply just do everything from
scratch and html so you have three
different options here
layouts themes and creating a template
on your own okay and that's either by
importing or by creating it from scratch
okay my recommendation
i like some of the layouts that
mailchimp has
you can see a lot of flexibility here
and when you actually choose one
again you're in full control of how to
design and message it so you're in full
control of that
so if you just want it again tell a
story i'm going to select this template
here
okay now i'm on the free version so keep
in mind
with the free version i don't have
access to all the templates so here i
get an upgrade to use this one but for
example
if i don't see the message upgrade to
use then i'm free to grab it so you can
see
the one column i'm free to use so i'm
just going to select that
and now i have this template available
to me so again i'm free to
edit this one as i see fit i mean i can
go ahead and
again drop in any one of these elements
that are available to me here i'm going
to drop in my social block
okay so here you can see i can now
customize my social block if i want to
add in another platform
i can do that social media platform
click save and close
so you can see they're very customizable
all of these themes and layouts are
very customizable and again when you're
done
it's just a matter of you can preview it
or test it you can enter preview mode or
you can send yourself a test
email okay if you send yourself a test
email you can actually see
how it looks when it comes in so let's
go ahead and do that here
so i'm just going to send myself a test
email and the email has been sent
so let's go check our inbox so here
is the email that i just created from
the theme
you can see here all i did simply when i
edited i just dropped in my social
block in here so this is what the email
looks like and the great thing about
mailchimp is they have an option that
you can view the email in a browser if
you can't
or you don't want to look at it in your
in this case i'm looking at gmail
so you can always or recipients can
always view the email in a browser
versus the email client that they're
using in specific
now when it comes to completing your
profile
on mailchimp you're going to need an
audience to send these emails to
and so when you click on audience here
if you don't have an audience already
imported into mailchimp you're going to
be asked to import
so you can see i already have one
contact that contacts me because i
added my email address on that test
email
so mailchimp is smart enough to say okay
we don't have this email address and our
contact list
so we're going to add them so here we
could see we can manage
our audience so we can add subscribers
we can import contacts
we can have sign up forms and we can
manage our contacts
so if we import our contacts if i click
on import
here i'm going to be asked to import
either from a csv
or copy and paste or i can just go ahead
and integrate it so if i
choose for example any one of these
then it's going to pull in the context i
have there
and so it's up to you how you import
your contacts
now the whole point of contacts is you
want to probably
or really not probably it's a best
practice to actually
create different lists so that you can
use different
audience lists with different emails and
so here you can see i have one email
address i can again
import contacts or i can add them
individually
so i can add subscribers here okay
that's another option that's the slower
option my recommendation be
import them but when you import make
sure you you're importing lists
that have some commonality so you can
manage those lists so
if you have one list that are say you
know clients who have never purchased
then you want to create a list for them
if you have clients who have purchased
separate those out okay so that's the
way i would go about it
now if you're trying to build a list
mailchimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form
then it's automatically going to get
added to your mailchimp account so
that's a great feature in mailchimp
that allows you to you know build out
your audience just by using one of their
forms
so again we have a subscriber pop-up
you've probably seen some of these on
some of the websites you've gone to
so you can customize it and if you want
somebody to subscribe to your newsletter
for example
all they need to do is enter in their
email address and click subscribe okay
that's the
the pop-up version now again you have
the opportunity to
you know use other forms as well so you
got a form builder here
or an embedded form okay where you can
integrate the form
okay so if i click form integrations
here i can use
wufoo or squarespace i can integrate
with them
if i go back to signup forms if i choose
form builder
here i have a sign up form and then i
can customize that form with different
boxes okay or fields okay so whatever
field i want somebody to
add information to i can have that in
there and then
this form could be you know on your
website so that's a great
feature about mailchimp is it helps you
build an audience so i can add this form
to my website and anybody who fills out
that form this is going to be
added to my subscriber list that i can
use for future emails
to take that a step further i can even
go from
building a form to building a landing
page so here you can see if i click on
audience
i can go ahead at the bottom right here
i have an option to create a landing
page so if they click on that
just like everything else in mailchimp
it's fairly easy to use i'm just going
to name it
test click begin here i can choose my
audience
again i can what audience do i want
to add these emails to i click begin
and i'm going to accept and here now i
have
all these different templates that i can
use as a lanny page
so if you want to use these landing
pages to collect
emails and those emails are going to be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here i'm just gonna choose one
you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page
so i can customize it just like i do
with my email template
i can add my logo okay i can start
adding different fields here like an
image i can drop an image here
okay i can go ahead and you know drop in
my social shares
okay i can drop in a box text box okay
and then i can start
customizing it with some text some
imagery
you know some other information again
this is a landing page that i can then
add to my website
and so anytime somebody goes to the
landing page and fills out their email
address and hits subscribe
it's going to be added to that audience
list
and then i can turn around and send an
email using one of mailchimp's templates
to that audience
so mailchimp really does a great job of
allowing you to grow your list within
your own website via a landing page
a form submission or or forum or pop-up
so there are lots of different options
available to us
so i'm going to click save and close
here and now this landing page is
available to me
so i can customize the url i can edit
the audience that these emails go to
i can add a page title and again i can
edit the design
so i can really make this an integrated
part of my website
by designing it so it fits the feel and
look
of my website i can add a specific url
and i can add a nice page title to it so
mailchimp again does a great job of just
making it so easy for you to build out a
landing page
for you to use on your website to
collect email addresses
so if you're doing a pay-per-click
campaign on facebook or google
you can actually drive traffic to these
landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is going to get added to your
audience that's an option or you can
just add it as part of your website and
people who go there from say organic
search
can find that page and add their email
address
organically so that's a great thing
about the audience feature
in mailchimp and that not only can you
select an
email template but you have options to
grow your audience okay
again importing contacts you can simply
just add contacts
you can add you know a form submission
via pop-up or regular form fields
to your website or you can add a landing
page so it's important to note that in
mailchimp if you go to the content
studio that's where you're going to find
all the files that you've added to all
your templates or landing pages that you
used before
so if i click on content studio here
here you can see the files i've added to
my templates
if you have products you can add your
products here okay so if you have an
e-commerce store
you could certainly add your products
and then those products can be used
on your landing page or your email
templates you have something called a
giphy
you can insert these into any of your
emails make it fun
exciting engaging here you have
instagram so
what you can do is you can integrate you
know any one of your instagram accounts
if you have multiple accounts or if you
have one instagram account you can
integrate that one
instagram account in with your mailchimp
account and when you do that it's going
to pull in all the images that you've
had
on instagram and then you have an
opportunity here just to add a logo okay
so you can use any of your instagram
images within your emails use one of
these cool
giffies again you can import your
products that you can use for your email
templates
or just keep tabs on all the files that
you've added before
just by clicking on my files now when
you get to the point
of building different audience lists
and sending down emails you're going to
have the option to
look at reporting to see how those
emails perform for those specific
audiences
now again an audience is a set it's like
a segment
you know these are set of individuals
who are going to receive a specific
email so
in this example you can see i have
different audiences and if we look at
say any one of these audience or even
just go to all audiences
we'll be able to see how we fared on
some of our emails
okay so for example if i send out an
email here
in april and this is april of 2019
i could see how many total subscribers
i've had
now along with the number of subscribers
you have
you have what we call open rate and
click-through rate
now we explain a lot of the reporting
and the specific email metrics and
another recording
that we did last week so if you're
interested in learning more about some
of the metrics
then check out the video that we have on
youtube email marketing tutorial
uh we recorded this last week go into
details about all the different metrics
you uh can learn about with email
marketing
so take a look at this video email
marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the mailchimp tutorial so
to give you some insights
as to what metrics to really pay
attention to with email marketing
but in mailchimp we know we can look at
the total number of subscribers
we know that we have how many opens and
we know what the open rate is and again
the total number of clicks
and what the click-through rate is okay
so with mailchimp very easily you just
hover over it
you get the raw number and then the
percentage so open rate is how many
people actually
open that email based on the total
number of people
that the email was sent to so here we
could see
in this particular email last year in
april
you know we've had fourteen percent
fourteen one point one percent to be
exact
and that is thirteen thousand three
hundred seventy seven divided by
ninety seven thousand four sixty nine so
that's how many people
open the email so thirteen thousand out
of ninety seven is about
14 now when somebody opens it
we hope they're going to click on it and
so here we got a
1.4 click-through rate again that's the
total number of clicks based on the
total number of subscribers or people
that were sent the email
and so mailchimp just gives you a nice
overview
of how many subscribers were in
this particular audience list and then
the open rating click rate so we can
really dive in here
and we can actually see how that
particular email performs so
if we just pick one email here we can
just click view report
we have other options here we can print
we can download we can share it the
whole campaign or just view the email if
we want to view what the email looked
like we could select that
so we just want to view the report so
we're going to click view report
and now we can get into some nice
detailed information
about the actual report itself so again
here you can see total number of
recipients and this came from the
audience list called newsletter
okay was delivered last year september
26 2018
again i have the option to view it
download it print it or share it
so let's take a look and view the email
to see what it looked like
okay so this is what the email look like
we have our own template here
and here you can see it takes into
account some of the best practices
involved with email marketing you know
we have some nice content
imagery some call to action here some
other links
okay we have our social icons okay so
that's what the email looked like okay
so we'll go back and we're going to
click
view report now we want to view the
report again
here's what it look here's when it was
sent okay the open rate for this was 21
click-through rate was 4 so for us
the list average this list here
newsletter
the average was for the open rate 16.8
so we're above the average on this email
for the click-through rate the list
average is 2.7
so we're above the average so we've done
a good job on this email at least
generating more opens more clicks and
mailchimp even takes that a step further
they'll even show you
what the industry average is for your
particular industry and in this case
we're education and training so we did
better
than the industry average for both the
open rate and for the click-through rate
so we could see some
other specifics we could see the raw
numbers of opens
clicks how many people bounced meaning
the email address wasn't valid anymore
and so mailchimp does a good job of any
email that actually bounces
it'll be scrubbed and removed from your
list and then here you can see 347
unsubscribe so the the thing about you
know
mailchimp is we want to be careful we
don't have too many unsubscribes
and also people abusing or reporting
abuse
meaning you don't want to send out an
email multiple multiple times a week
where it gets the point where it's
spammy and so you want to avoid
a high number of unsubscribes and a high
number of abuse reports
and so here you can see most emails are
open within a 24-hour period and then it
kind of just tails off
so here we can see opens and clicks
based on the time of day
so within 24 hour period okay so this is
how most
emails operate within that first 24
hours
you're going to get a lot of opens a lot
of clicks and then it's going to tail
off from there
great thing is mailchimp provides me
more detailed information about what was
clicked
so i could see here the top links that
were clicked
and let me just point one thing out here
whether you use mailchimp
or you use any other platform whether
that be vertical response
or any other type of email marketing
platform
you want to use utm tracking with your
links
so that google analytics can pick up
the actual campaign so here you can see
we have utm
tracking appended to our links and let
me just go in
to detail on that for just a minute so
mailchimp again gives us nice data on
open and click-through rates but when we
send out an email and people actually do
click on one of these links they're
going to go to our website and from
there
google analytics is going to take over
on the tracking so this is as far as
mailchimp goes so we want to be able to
bridge the gap between mailchimp
reporting
and google analytics meaning when they
came from the
email when and went to the site did they
convert meaning did they download
something did they purchase something
and so we want to be able to bridge the
gap and utm tracking
which is simply appending the original
url
with some tracking parameters named utm
it allows us to bridge that gap so all
you need to do
when you set up a mailchimp campaign is
just go to url builder
in google then you're going to click on
campaign
url builder and we're going to go ahead
and set up an email campaign so for
example
if we go back here this was the original
url
so if i just copy this original url here
and paste that as part of my website url
what's my campaign source i'm gonna put
mailchimp what's my medium i'm gonna put
email so mailchimp is the source of
where the
traffic came from the medium the means
in which they
arrived at our website was via email and
then the campaign name
we're just gonna put maybe whatever it
is summer promo
so with the url builder you have five
parameters for utm tracking you don't
have to use all five okay
so here we need to put in the url and we
need to put in the source but the other
four parameters medium name term and
content are optional so you don't have
to put anything there but
the more parameters you put in the more
specific it is for you to track the
behavior of that email campaign
so here i can see mailchimp email summer
promo
and then for the content i can use that
to differentiate
my subject lines so when you send out an
email we mention this in the email
marketing tutorial
you always want to send out multiple
subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets this
a second subject line because you want
to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so i
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the url builder once i enter in my
parameters
it's going to append the original url
with
a new url appended with utm tracking so
if i copy that
i can simply just paste that in my
browser just to see if it works
and here you can see it works the page
loaded
the original url with utm tracking and
so that's exactly what you want to do
because when you're looking at your
reports in mailchimp
it's going to show me the top links that
were clicked now if i go into analytics
i want to be able to see how that
campaign or how that link actually
performed so let's take a look at that
real quick
so if i go to my google analytics
account and i go to acquisition
campaigns all campaigns what am i
looking for well
if i click on source and medium source
and medium are to the parameters
for utm tracking i'm going to look for
mailchimp so here i can see
i'm original url mailchimp and then the
date stamp
and then the medium's email so if i go
back here i can see for example
any one of these mailchimp emails that
went out and then i can see
how many people actually came from the
email what the balance rate was meaning
if they arrived on the site did they
leave
after arriving or did they actually go
to another page and then i could see
other engagement data like how many
pages they looked at
did they how much time did they spend
more importantly did they convert
so that's the whole idea behind using
utm tracking
because with utm tracking you can can
bridge the gap
from open rate click-through rate to
behavior on the website
all the way through to the conversion
and that's what we want to measure we
want to measure
did somebody go from the email open it
click on one of the links go to the
website engage on the website and
convert and so that's the whole idea
behind
utm tracking because mailchimp and any
other
email marketing platform is only going
to give you at most
your open rates and your click-through
rates okay so here we could see
the top links clicked i see 4 000
recipients clicked on this email they
went to the site
and now i need analytics to kind of tell
me the rest and here i can see what
subscribers
had the most opens and if i integrated
social
i can see some social performance and so
that goes back to our original setup so
if you integrate your twitter account or
your facebook account
you'll be able to integrate that email
in with your twitter
and then from there i'll be able to see
you know tweets
or or how many likes for example and to
top it off i can see
how many people from around the world
clicked on the email
so that's reporting in a nutshell on
mailchimp
reports are fairly easy to look at you
know all sorts of other
information like links specifically
links
you can look at social so if i click on
the social
tab here if i integrated my social i can
look at social reporting
likewise for e-commerce and notice
analytics 360 i can integrate
google analytics in with mailchimp if i
want to
so i have all sorts of options on my
reporting
so that's it for mailchimp i mean it's
fairly easy to navigate
you have all the campaigns that you've
sent out so if you just click on
campaigns
i'll be able to see all the campaigns
i've set up and all the campaigns that
have been sent
and obviously the ones that have been
sent i can start looking at reports
i can pick and choose templates okay i
can pick and choose my
audience and manage my audience okay i
can see what the growth is for my
audience
again i have different options to grow
my audience
okay i can certainly add form
submissions landing pages
sign up forms i can import more contacts
and i can manage them through different
lists content studio
is where all your files are going to be
located from
the files you've uploaded to e-commerce
products to githi's to instagram
to my logo and then you have reports and
the reports are there
for you to measure the performance of
your email campaigns once they've been
sent so you can look at them from
reports
or just from the main campaigns view
that's pretty much it
so if you're ready to go at it again
click that create button
click that template choose that audience
you can go ahead and send yourself that
test email when you're ready
go ahead and send that email off to your
audience it's that simple in mailchimp
we're going to cover emo marketing
interview questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's going to work
so if you have any questions to these
questions or answers feel free
to just comment right below this video
and we'll
get back to you as soon as possible
we're going to go through a series of
questions and i'm going to answer those
questions for you
so email marketing's traditional digital
marketing channel it's been around a
while
and you're going to be asked some
questions that are going to encompass a
lot of things
related to the delivery of emails
we all check emails on a daily basis we
all receive them
sometimes we receive emails unsolicited
sometimes we sign up to receive emails
sometimes we receive emails from
friends sometimes we receive emails
where
we're working or previously worked so
most people have an understanding of
email however
as a marketer there's a little bit of a
different twist to it
so we have to understand the intricacies
of how
email marketing works so you're gonna be
asked some questions
and really the first question here is
what's the difference between a hard
and a soft balanced email so if you're a
digital marketer you're in charge of
sending out lots of emails
let's just say thousands or i mean it
could be in the
hundreds of thousands of emails you're
gonna get some bounces and so you really
want to know the difference between a
hard
and a soft bounce so a soft bounce just
means that the email message
reached the recipient's mail server
but bounce back is undelivered so think
of it as
delivering actual mail to a post office
so it actually reached the post office
but it bounced back because maybe
the you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to
handle that email now hard balance is an
email that that is rejected because
it's an email when it happens when the
email has been permanently rejected so
for example maybe the the the account is
no longer valid and so let's look at
some reasons again
as to why a soft bounce would happen so
for example the inbox is full or
the recipient servers down so reach the
post office
but there was a problem actually getting
it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different
let's just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted
or you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay
a spam or something to that effect so
the email server is going to identify
that
and it's not even going to reach the
recipient so a lot of different ways
in which an email may not make its
recipient
so now the most important thing to know
here i just the important thing to know
is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many
get bounced back and so next question
here what would you do to improve the
click-through rate
of your email so click-through rate is
simply
how many people have seen your email and
how many people actually clicked on a
link
in the email so if a hundred people saw
your email but only one person clicked
then it would be a one percent
click-through rate
so we want to be able to make sure we
have a high click-through rate
so remember emails are going to people
who likely signed up to receive your
email
and even if they are expecting an email
or they're not expecting an email you
still want to follow some of these best
practices here
one is to create a compelling subject
line so you want to make the subject
line
something that people are going to
notice take note of
or take an interest in and say hey
what's this all about that's pretty
interesting
and open the email so use preview text
effectively
obviously you want to make your email
mobile friendly because most people look
at their emails on their mobile phones
you want to create engaging content okay
so
the content that's in the email
obviously is going to have some links
so put some strong call to action in
there and that's one of the bullet
points down below
place a cta where it's easily visible so
keep in mind
mobile users most people are going to
check that email on their phone so you
want to make sure you have compelling
content with good
ctas in a visible location so always
check
mobile as well as desktop obviously in
your emails you want to make them
as visual as possible don't make them so
text heavy
you can always segment your emails
meaning if you're sending out an email
let's just say to 100 people
okay maybe you want to divide it up boys
or girls maybe
older or young maybe you know
living in one part of the country versus
another part of the country i mean those
are examples of segments so
break up the email don't send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then a b test your emails and when
we say a b
test you know you can send out the same
email twice
except one segment is going to say get
one version of the email the other
segment is going to get another version
of email and what are the different
versions
maybe the subject line so the subject
line is different on version a
versus version b or maybe the call to
action is different so you always want
to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see
which segment or which version got the
most clicks
okay so next question here is how to
inform your customers about company news
and establish
a relationship with your target audience
okay so again how do
you inform your customers about what's
going on in the company
and how are you going to establish a
relationship with that audience who's
receiving that email
well newsletters are always the best
answer here
so somebody signs up for your email
let's just say they actually
purchase a product from you newsletters
are great way to reach out to that
audience to get them to
stay up to date with the latest product
or an improved version of the product
they purchased
and then that way they can come back and
continue to purchase the product
so newsletters are great way to reach
out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking
verbally you're talking to them via
email so you send out that email
campaign maybe it's once a month hey
we noticed you bought this product we
have similar products just like the one
you bought or
hey you know if it's a software maybe
hey we've got
upcoming updates to our software make
sure you go to the website and get the
updates
or we have a new and improved version so
all these things you want to communicate
to your audience via email
that's going to get them to get to the
website and that's going to get them to
you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever
so newsletters the way to go so again
some basic tips here
you want to create your newsletter with
90 educational and 10 percent
promotional so remember you're sending
out a newsletter to people who
likely signed up so you're educating
them about
your products always create interesting
subject lines you want
whether they know you or not you want to
create the subject line so somebody's
going to click on it
so make sure you design your emails
appropriately okay
so if you know you're sending let's just
say baby products
to mothers or expected mothers in fact
this is a real life example because i
used to work at
a gap and baby gap was
you know one of the emails groups i was
responsible for so we created an email
template with
softer colors your yellows your your
light blues
you know it wasn't black or dark red or
anything that's going to be
you know heavy we knew who our audience
was and we designed the template
accordingly and of course
using compelling images so for selling
baby products
you're going to put baby product images
in there i mean it's common sense but
you'd be surprised you gotta pick and
choose your images carefully especially
if you're sending to an international
audience because images
can be misconstrued and just like we
mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to have a clear cta
always make sure you have a cta in a
visible position
because most people are going to look at
that email in a mobile phone
okay and then always make sure you
include your contact information in the
newsletter
so somebody knows where to find you how
to contact you where to go
maybe they have a product they want to
return okay so you always want to put
that contact information
normally it's at the bottom of the email
but these are all best practices
so here's some examples okay we got
you know check out the latest cosmetics
from our new collections notice the
image
and notice the call to action so you can
see trendy collections you know we got
some other
products you may want to buy okay five
important skin care products that
everyone should have
view more so you always want to have
that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate
so these are metrics related to email
marketing so you're gonna have to know
what these are
so we already mentioned click-through
rate before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so
for those of you that remember what that
is go ahead and put that
in the comment section below just a
little pop quiz for you
if anybody remembers click-through rate
but let's take a look at open rate
so open rate is the percentage of the
total number of recipients
who actually open the email so if you
send it to x amount of people how many
people
opened it that would be the open rate so
how many people open it but you're gonna
take out the people who bounced it
whether it's a soft bounds a hard bounce
okay you're not gonna count those people
so if you have let's just say 20 people
open the email and you sent it to a
hundred people
then and you had nobody balanced then it
would be a 20 open rate okay
click-through rate
again pop quiz it's just how many people
actually
clicked on any of the links in your
email
and that's just divided by the number of
emails you've sent out a response rate
okay so response rate is the percentage
of the total recipients
who clicked on the link of your email
campaign and actually complete it in
action
so what is that action well it could be
downloading something
watching something purchasing something
so that's the response rate similar to
conversion rate if you're working in a
digital marketing channel and you're
driving traffic to the site you want
that traffic to do something well it's
no different in email marketing we want
people to take action
we're just going to divide that by the
number of emails delivered and that
gives you
your response rate so let's just say you
did send in 100
emails you did get 20 open it
and of this 20 let's just say one person
went on a purchase
well you'd have a one percent response
rate and then a forward rate
simply the forward rate refers to the
rate at which your subscribers share
your email
uh with others friends family etc and
you may
have that as a call to action in your
email in fact that's a best practice
so it's just the number of clicks on a
share divided by the total number of
delivered emails
and you're going to multiply that by 100
to get the percentage and so
most email marketing platforms do
measure
forward rate okay let's take a look at
how to recapture
inactive customers what you want to do
here is re-engage subscribers with
gamification opt for subject lines like
we have been missing you or
did we do something wrong you want to
run a poll
or a competition and re-engage their
subscribers again
trying to get people involved these
first three are all about getting people
involved
so personalize your emails talk to that
person as if
hey look i haven't heard from you in a
while how about coming back
and taking a look at our new products
just as you would a friend
so design always matters especially
knowing that you're talking to customers
who haven't been active okay this is a
segmented audience
somebody who's inactive so you want to
have the right design the right message
the right subject line that fits with
that
customer's inactivity so you want to try
and do everything you can to get that
customer back
and then you want to follow a consistent
schedule
okay so ideally when you schedule an
email you want to schedule the best time
so you have to know your audience
obviously and then you can always ask
for
feedback why are they inactive why
haven't they purchased in a while
so the whole idea here from gamification
like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive
to adding polls to really personalizing
it these are all things that you can do
to get your customers back
so what are the different ways to
segment buyer personas so
again when we talk about segmentation
we're talking about taking a smaller
piece the entire pie so
what's one way to break up that pie if
you will by geography
okay so with geography you could target
your audience based on
that area and it could not necessarily
have to be by a part of the country it
could be all the way down to
the province the state the actual city
the county
okay if you live in a small village okay
all the way up to the continent
okay so think about how you would break
out the segment by
geography now obviously if you break it
out let's just say the united states
to the southern part well the southern
part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cold to say the
northern part so
that should tell you hey we're going to
send an email in the winter
we're not going to use snow and
blizzards
as our theme we're going to use probably
a little bit of sun
so breaking it out by geography helps
you understand
where your audience lives you also have
demographic segmentation and this is
simply just
age education income gender you know
where people work okay nationality
anything that's going to identify that
user so this is the best way to segment
if you know who your audience is
by income or gender i mean you're
talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately
and you're not going to talk to an older
person the same way you would a younger
person so
think about demographic segmentation
because it really helps you
hone in on your messaging and you have
behavioral segmentation so behavioral is
based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased
were they searching for something how
long did they stay on the site
what products were they looking at are
they a lifetime customer
so you can look at behavior and decide
how you want to break out your emails by
behavior
and this is a really good way if you're
not even sure who your audience is or
where they live
and how old they are you could certainly
break out your audience by behavior
because you know who these people
are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that
information with analytics so you know
one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased
that's a good way to segment because you
know these people
believe in you believe in your business
believe in your product so
the way you can message to somebody
who's purchased before is going to be
different
than somebody you don't even know who
they are if they purchased or not okay
so behavioral segmentation to me
is one of the easiest things the easiest
ways to segment your email list
how would you drive repeat customers
through email marketing for the below
scenario
okay so this is a pop quiz if you will
again for those of you that got click
the rate correctly
kudos let's see if you can go two for
two here okay so if you know the answer
to this go ahead and comment
below but let's just say give a few
examples of subject lines to drive
engagement for audiences based on the
following provide an audience between
20 and 30 years old that were female and
the product were sandals
okay what would some of your subject
lines be so i'm going to give you a
minute
to think about that and put it in the
comment section below
now remember this is an interview based
question
so you're gonna have to think on the
spot i'm gonna give you a minute but
if somebody presented that to you in an
interview you need to be able to
you know react fairly quickly and come
up with some really attractive subject
lines here
okay so here you go here's another one
uh
so give a few examples of subject lines
to drive engagement for
20 to 30 females for footwear so you got
friday sale coming up
buy branded sandals at the lowest price
okay so i like this one because it's got
a strong call to action buy here you go
this is even better because
50 off on branded sandals and free
shipping i mean who can't
beat free anything including shipping
and if it's 50
off i mean these are key things you're
putting the promotion and percentage off
all in the subject line so that's really
going to grab somebody's attention
we can see for women starts now okay
with a little emoji that never hurts
so those are all good subject lines they
all
tend to work because they all have an
element of a best practice in there
so here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people
notice okay the stronger call to action
on the buy you're putting the promotion
in the subject line
and you know using an emoji to really
just drive home the point
so all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines
okay moving on to the next question
speaking of testing
what is a b testing and give some
examples of a b testing okay so we
talked a little bit about a b
testing with subject lines so simply a b
testing when it comes to email marketing
it's just a method to analyze
which of the two email campaign
strategies is most effective
all right you know you're gonna do it
based on open rate you can do it by
saying click rate you can do it based on
response rate
and remember you're putting one version
of the email against another version
whether that be the subject line whether
it be the content
call to action whatever so that's
ideally what you're trying to do you're
trying to figure out
what works for your audience that's the
end goal for email for a b testing and
email marketing what's going to work
and i would highly suggest you should
always do a b testing for subject lines
always so some of the variables that you
can test
again subject lines okay you always want
to try if you got a
promotion hey will the percentage off
work likely it will but let's test it up
against something else like
you know a generic word like discounts
you can always
test the design you can always test the
personalization
the preview text you could try out
images call to actions
exclusive offers what particular offer
is going to work
okay so if you're testing offers then
obviously that's going to be response
rate if you're testing
ctas and that's going to be
click-through rate if you're testing
subject lines that's going to be
open rate so you want to be able to test
different elements of the email to
figure out
what works and what doesn't work okay so
how to prevent
email from getting into spam so if
you're an email marketer this is your
worst nightmare
you don't want your emails to get
spammed so
that doesn't bode well for you so most
email marketing
platforms like mailchimp or constant
contact
measure spam so some of the important
ways to prevent this is
hey improve your open rate remember
going back to the first question
second question you want to have really
good subject lines here okay and you
want to segment your audience so if
you're if you know who you're talking to
and you have a cool
subject line that's going to get
somebody to react and open and that's
going to prevent somebody from spamming
your email
okay you can always customize your from
to make it look like it's coming from in
this case rob
sanders check if you have included an
unsubscribe link
okay so give people the option to
unsubscribe they don't have the option
to unsubscribe
they could just report you as spam make
sure your emails work on different
devices
okay you want to optimize your images
for email make sure they're not
big and they don't fit on a mobile
device okay
prefer more text and fewer images and
then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come across as professional
you don't want somebody looking at your
email like who sent this
why are you sending this to me i don't
want to hear from you again i'm going to
spam you
you want to prevent that and that means
a professional looking email
professional content with a really good
subject line and some imagery to go
along with that
hey you may just get somebody to open
that email and get them to convert
that's the idea behind it so these are
ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then
what are the best practices for email
subject lines so the subject line is the
most
probably the most important element in
email marketing
so we talked about that little pop quiz
with the sandals
targeting 20 to 30 year old women you
know to me i like the subject line with
the 50 off so that was a number in the
subject line so people can actually see
hey wow i get a whole fifty percent that
works better than just a discount
okay remember one of those other subject
lines had an emoji so don't be afraid to
include emojis in there for example
when i send out emails using you know
during the spring you might want to use
flowers
perhaps to signify hey it's spring
winter's over
so personalize the subject lines
remember that goes with segmenting
so if you know who your audience is your
your subject lines can be a little bit
more partial okay so opt for
title case subject lines okay so instead
of
making it grammatical for example okay
you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
out
and boring then people aren't going to
open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through friday
so that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday
i better open this email and check it
out and again grammatical mistakes that
goes without saying
you always want to preview your emails
before you send them out
so if you preview your emails before you
send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes
for you to prevent any mistakes but also
give you feedback
on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines
okay so subject line is the most
important element
for email marketing so just keep these
in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines
is the way to get people to open it and
from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email
then you've just set yourself up for
better performance and with that we have
come to the end of this video on
email marketing full course i hope it
was informative
and interesting if you have any
questions about the topics governed in
this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning